or pro-israel groups are demanding that
songwriter musician and Pink Floyd
co-founder Roger Waters be dropped from
the South by Southwest Music Festival in
Texas next month they claim the star is
an anti-semite and therefore undeserving
to share his views there it is
unconscionable that waters be given any
platform to air his anti-semitic views
much less the chance to be a keynote
speaker at a major Music Festival South
by Southwest should remove him from its
lineup immediately well Roger Waters is
scheduled to be keynote speaker at that
festival that last year attracted more
than 400,000 people and earlier a major
baseball league in the u.s. announced
that they won't be running ads for
waters upcoming tour after they came
under pressure as well we can now be
joined live by the man himself Roger
Waters to get his take on the story
thanks for joining us so much Roger
goods having the program today we have
how did you receive the news about this
the band from the lead why did they how
do they explain this decision to you
well they didn't of course it's a
complete lie that's been made up by
Daniel and Charles my old friends from
B'nai berry major league baseball ran
some pre sale ads before a pre-sale of
tickets for my shows which was very nice
I've always had a very good relationship
with the MLB I've done shows the Yankee
Stadium and Wrigley Field and Fenway
Park and other great great baseball
stadiums all over the United States so I
have a close relationship with him and
so there was never any question of us
continuing to run more ads after the
pre-soak period so I think they just
lent let it let it go away quietly but
then these guys constantly lie about
everything
I don't you know the life starting with
the lie that I am an avowed anti-semite
to be an avowed anti-semite I would have
to allow it you can't allow that
I can't allow that
Charlson Daniel I sorry I keep
forgetting their names educationally
subnormal they might admit that or say
or they could about anything about
themselves but they can't about me I've
never done anything anti-semitic or had
an anti-semitic thought in my life I do
have a support the BDS movement and I am
and I have campaigned for the last 15
years or so
against the policies of the Israeli
government and I will continue to do so
until the human rights of the
Palestinian people are respected in the
Middle East we would come back to that
in just a moment mr. waters what about
the South by Southwest festival I've
heard anything on that front about that
case
now I haven't I mean obviously I've
heard that they have invited me to make
the keynote speech at the beginning of
the music industry section and I'm very
happy that they have I've never been to
a South by Southwest obviously I've been
to Austin it's a very famously great
music town in Texas so I'm much looking
forward to rubbing shoulders with I hope
like-minded people who are interested in
the sharing of ideas and also interested
in some of the other things that I'm
interested in that Charles and Daniel
are not things like freedom and
democracy and freedom of speech and
human rights and so on and so forth but
we will see I I haven't heard so far of
any attack I just heard now for the
first time on your program the that guy
whoever that was attacking the idea that
I should be that they should be allowed
to invite me just in terms of your
support for Palestinian rights for the
the BDS movement obviously it is a
movement that has attracted some
controversy from all sides as well being
equated with anti-semitism did you
foresee that sort of a reaction when you
express support for the movement well
you know the the equation of the BDS
movement with anti-semitism is an
invention of people
like B'nai B'rith and it's an invention
of the Ministry of strategic affairs
which spends millions and millions of
pounds all over the world that so the
Israeli Ministry set up specifically to
spread lies about BDS there is nothing
anti-semitic about BDS the BDS movement
has consistently and constantly and
unequivocally stated that it is against
all all forms of isms racism
anti-semitism anti-muslim Islam ofor
anything any of any of any of those race
hatred or anti religious movements of
anywhere BDS absolutely disavows itself
from and it's always been extremely
clear about that and so am i i believe
that all human beings are brothers and
sisters all over the world and that we
have an absolute moral duty to respect
one another and if possible to nurture
and care for one another as much as we
possible can that that is what human
rights is about that's what Paris 1948
and the Universal Declaration was about
and that is the tiny platform upon which
I stand clearly on being mildly
sarcastic when I say tiny it's a huge
platform human rights are more important
than almost anything they lead us out of
the darkness into the light
anti-semitism obviously has been a
problem across the world though do you
think such allegations as we said
earlier equated at the BDS movement with
anti-semitism accusing you of being an
anti-semite do you think that's more of
a hindrance than a help to the cause of
fighting all forms of racism as well as
anti-semitism yeah of course it is
because it muddies the water for one
very over one very very specific issue
which is the issue of the settler
colonial occupation of the land of
Palestine by Israeli Armed Forces and
and and they forced exile of the people
whose land it was in 1948 where does
honest operations started so it muddies
all of those waters I believe my belief
is that human rights should be something
that is fundamental that applies to all
people equally and and clearly the
israel-palestine issue is a glaring
example of somewhere where some people
have rights and other people don't
for instance the Palestinians don't have
any rights at all and the and the
Israelis have lots of rights and and so
so it's complex issue but I wish I could
think I know we've got very little time
so I wish I could think and speak
quicker because it the reason and that
it's brought up constantly is so that we
will not address the fundamental issue
of whether what I say is true or not
that is why the IHRA definition when it
cropped up and was adopted and has been
adopted by Trump and by others as a new
definition of anti-semitism is such a
red herring because it doesn't come from
any real genuine body the IHRA is a
nebulous NGO it has nothing to do with
the UN it has nothing to do with human
rights organizations and in consequence
it it is the new definition definition
which identifies any criticism of the
policies both domestic and foreign of
the State of Israel as being inherently
anti-semitic is clearly nonsense if you
look if you look at it in any real way
but it gets headlines and it's quoted
constantly they quoted Charles and
Daniel Rhodes that in the letter they
wrote suggesting that the Major League
Baseball's should be ashamed of itself
major league baseball shouldn't
shamed of itself they should leave Major
League Baseball alone this is just them
trying to muddy the water should human
beings have rights oh no this is
question that you have to face in Moscow
I have to face in London and and we all
have to face all over the world and it's
extremely important because we don't
brand each other
equal rights as individual human beings
is very difficult to imagine a path
forward towards a more towards a world
that might survive
for instance hmm we do have a bit of
time left we'll just so you can take
your time to think and speak as you want
what would you say in answer to to your
accusers who have accused you of of
anti-semitism and you know such as the
the Simon Wiesenthal Center they've
particularly been critical for example
of your use of they legend inflatable
pig bearing the Star of David during
previous concerts what would you say to
those accusers that I've said that you
know you are going too far you are
engaging indirectly in anti-semitism and
you know offending Jews what would your
message be to those who accuse you of
those things well God how many more
times in my life am I gonna have to
describe the theatrical device that I
used in the wall shows which was a rock
and roll show with theatrics in it where
at a certain point I go fascist I put on
a leather coat I wear an armband that's
got crossed hammers on it you know you I
couldn't get any closer and to national
socialism in terms of the look of the
thing if I tried at the time as one of
my props I have an inflatable Pig and I
covered this pig with maybe 20 symbols I
can't remember them all now of different
of different organisations or that I
felt were a malign
Curren the Star of David represents the
State of Israel in this thinking and it
is it's in a part a country it would be
anywhere let's not go there what I want
where I want to go is I also had a
crucifix on it
no Christian Association has come up to
me and said oh my god you're
anti-christian how could you put a cross
on the pig that you flew in 2013 at a
show in Belgium in yeah you know in
Belgium and say has any Muslim come to
me and said you had a crescent and star
on the page how dare you you your anti
you're obviously in Islam Islamophobic
you know there was also a dollar sign
that nobody's come to me from the
Federal Reserve or the Treasury said how
dare you attack the currency of the
United States of America
you're obviously crazy and so on and so
forth there were lots more it even it
even there were lots and lots more of
these things and I since they were
theatrical devices that I used in the
show I don't regret it I think it was
perfectly legitimate however when there
was a problem about it back in 2013 I
thought you know what
it doesn't materially affect my theatre
to remove the Star of David and vine so
it did and they're still bleating am
whining be rabbi Cooper from the Simon
Wiesenthal Center I mean I know the
man's name well he is rabid I don't mean
to get into ad hominem attacks about him
but it is incredibly dull and boring and
Li I've been able to withstand it you
know lucky are there are enough people
who are interested in what I think and
feel and who follow my work my music and
and my songs and so on and so forth that
the rabbi Cooper's of this world are
finding it very difficult to destroy me
and and I have looked I'm going back on
the road this summer but it is annoying
it's really a noise like it's like
aiming a fly buzzing around
Roger we are running out of time just
slightly but just going back to the
third question what would your message
be to those who accuse you of
anti-semitism and do you see more
actions from the pro-israel groups
against you accusing you of these things
yeah my message would be don't do it
it's foolish you need to come up with a
river you need to come up with a defense
for your side of the argument or whether
or whether it is correct or not for the
Israeli government to be operating a
system of a partakes in the country that
used to be called Palestine okay you
have whether you believe in in the
United Nations Universal Declaration of
Human Rights from Paris in 1948 or not
because clearly given your policies you
the Israeli dump not you Jewish people
this has nothing to do with Jewish
people and by the way B'nai B'rith
at the bottom of their letter which I
read again today they claim to represent
all Jewish people all over the world
well I'm sorry guys but you don't you do
not you know I obviously I follow Jewish
boys for peace a lot who are becoming a
more and more powerful voice for Jewish
people particularly in the United States
so you don't rip them all you represent
some of them maybe but you know we need
to be able to look at these things
directly without slinging mud and
calling people names that don't fit I am
NOT anti-semitic don't say it anymore
please because it is a barefaced lie and
it's irritating and it does nobody any
good